[Musik]
sogar der tiefe kommen heute zu einem
neuen video feature was ich mit der hand
halte und es war er hier das ganze video
jetzt nicht gesponsert von denen ich
habe das nicht kostenlos bekommen er
gute gewissen form habe ich schon
kostenlos bekommen video 71 als mein
management die haben ja diese drohne
zugeschickt und meinte du musst damit
nichts machen aber fünfmal war ist ganz
cool und fakt ist die droge kleiner
alter hier sitzt drin und geben euch mal
die kleinen diese
die so groß wie meine hand auf jeden
fall ist das eine drohne die man die
fliegenfalle man hat eine brille dabei
durch die brille kann man sehen was die
drohne sieht cool freut mich hier
verpacken wie das jetzt erst mal auf und
dann sehen wir zuvor wieder wenn das
ganze aufgepasst ein paar sekunden
später
[Musik]
welcher patient und gar nicht gesehen
wir haben jetzt die gerade alles ausgibt
hat die fucking verpackung wie ich jetzt
leer auf jeden fall darin enthalten eine
brille wo aber kein bildschirm drin
sondern wir müssen unser eigenes handy
reinpacken hey cool hätte man vielleicht
auch mal sagen können ganz viel haben
sie wie das ganze aufgebaut ist hier so
ein bisschen kleinen scheiß ich musste
mir jetzt gerade noch hier sondern
herunterladen
das handy klemm weg war sie gleichen
diese brillen und davon ist unsere
drohne waffenarsenal von nordkorea usa
ihr könnt nichts gegen eine drohne
hier steht jetzt in der app gleich
liegen die los schalten sie zuerst die
drohne eine lebens- den kleinen schalter
auf der rückseite betätigten legen sie
auch eine flache oberfläche ab
[Musik]
wetzel müller immer irgendwie sehen die
ganzen ihm schon wieder was hat man die
drohne ist hier an und wie ihr seht
schon hier vorne die sucht jetzt weitere
typen und wir dritten drauf vielleicht
funktioniert das noch nicht so richtig
bewegen sie als nächstes den linken
joystick auf ihren controller nach unten
drücken sie danach die bauerschaft auf
ihrem konto oder uni einzuschalten
sagen wir schließen den mal ab hier vom
ladekabel und bewegen uns jetzt mal eine
flache oberfläche
kingsley geist auf jeden fall auch mit
die drohne jetzt hier auf einer flachen
oberfläche dh wir verfolgen jetzt immer
die anleitung drückt kann ich hier
nochmal einen drauf und jetzt bei der
[Musik]
wahl also die steuerung ist echt
komplett also ich kann keinen beginnt
kann ich hier draufklicken dann leider
nicht durchgehend jahr bleiben auf ihren
sitz hier fällig jetzt muss zur racing
captain und natürlich der neue app
runterladen machen sie mit dem
controller
ja ich sehe was die drohne sieht da
kommt die sonne zieht also das hier ist
jetzt quasi das was die drohne habe das
grüne hätte wenn sie bereit sind ok
angst du bereit bist du gerade
ich drücke mich jetzt hier aus hat er
gar nichts dieser moment wenn ein handy
zu gruppe bis jetzt haben wir ein zufall
dass der look bekommen hätte ich den
posten achten dass die hatte das super
minister von de wit league lernen wir
jetzt hier
jetzt machen wir das jetzt alles perfekt
geklappt wir können das ding mal auf
meinen schweden schiedel aufsetzen oma
wie ich gerade auf dem teppich mit der
drohne aber was ist das 800 einflusslos
ja vor den fluss und hier gut nicht
darüber gesprochen
glückwunsch sie haben das war das
training abgeschlossen das ist bisschen
gute rente sichern
quatsch also sieht das ganze jetzt quasi
aus der drohne haus also man hat das war
sie auf und man sie quasi nichts außer
dass hier und wenn ich jetzt
beispielsweise
es liege also schaut euch das mal an wir
uns wie die throne hoch ich bin jetzt
filme die drohne davos und jetzt mal ja
natürlich würde sagen darf es auch mal
fliegen erkennen
gerade was die drohne für sie oder er
leckte machte immer unendlich grenzenlos
lernen sie die drohne an einem sicheren
ort sichere wartet also wir lassen jetzt
die drohte hier erst mal so ein bisschen
laden das heißt wir sehen uns jetzt
gleich wieder wenn ihr drohne fertig ist
ich packe ich jetzt von einwendungen
eingegangen
deswegen dauert 2000 jahren die drohne
jetzt ein bisschen laden lassen befinden
uns jetzt mal sacken im auto und auf
jeden fall fahren wir jetzt in
irgendeinem park auf irgend eine wiese
oder keine ahnung irgendwie was um damit
der droht oder was ein bisschen zu
fliegen
man merkt hier das ist der drohnen
landeplatz
[Musik]
wir befinden uns jetzt hier im
grüngürtel meine damen und herren einer
mit von den besten orten in köln ist
schwarzer gürtel weil ich gut den
kämpfen kämpfen das ist nämlich der
drohnen landeplatz wir können auch
einfach unseren drohnen befestigungs
beute hier darüber hängen kann
hervorragend als im wasserglas oder fax
ist der falsche wasser im beutel drin
doch hast du tun kannst du wasser da
stimmt der auvergne wasser in den beutel
falls einer frage hier haben wir unsere
brille am start natürlich meine damen
und herren und hier haben wir unsere
drohen und die haben die ganze zeit hier
mit so wenig dumm und hat sie nicht
geladen auf jeden fall haben jetzt hier
und so drohen am start ich würde sagen
wir packen jetzt mal vom ladekabel
wegpacken jetzt mal hier auf den die die
drohnen land lahm der controller
natürlich auch am start für den crafter
des kjr faktor kommt wasser kontrolle ja
krass dass du so viel wasser in den
beutel rein ja jetzt so viel wasser drin
war aber nicht so gut drauf drücken uns
kommt das wasser raus ja ja nicht dass
wir noch als gut die drohne ist auf
jeden fall aufgeladen ich nehme jetzt
mal mein handy raus und öffnet mal
wieder die app wir befinden uns jetzt
hier gerade in der drohne das heißt
schon wenn ich jetzt meinen fuß mit der
barbarischen tat ein food den andern in
arabien ist es das schlimmste wenn die
man den fuß zeigen dass handys sind
wieder hier in unserem so unglaublich
bequem mit helmen drin ja heiß heiß heiß
heiß weiß es gibt beim neuen iphone so
zimmer warum sind eigentlich wege wenn
wir noch eine wiese fahren kann
im herrenhaus ist bereits level okay
jetzt schon okay jetzt geht's los meine
damen im alter ist ärztin die drohne
aber ihr handy bringen drohen jetzt
liegen
[Musik]
hallo kann ich mein fahrrad ist noch
möglich ja klar selbstverständlich
also wir haben diese rolle jetzt mehr
oder weniger richtig repariert
also für hin kostet sie einigermaßen
vernünftig und fliegen dann hätte ich
sie gar nicht mehr wusste ich kann aber
ganz köln gerade
[Musik]
ich weiß es liege stehst du bist ja
opfer gefallen also ich schwöre die ohne
spaß
ich war auf der höhe von diesem scheiß
dauer ich konnte immer ganz köln drohen
im signal verloren sie müssen näher an
ihrer drohne sein
ich glaube ich glaube dass nach
deutschland gelangen safed da vorne
irgendwo 316 später haben die drohne
tatsächlich wiedergefunden freunde aber
zumindest hier auf dem dings also liegt
unter einem baum auf dem grat 30 welcher
baumwipfel meinte waren auch für das
telekom dauert künftig an die umwelt die
muss auf jeden fall den richtung eines
baumes gruppen sieben der veda gmbh
meine damen und herren ich muss wirklich
sagen dazu beginnen nicht zu begeistert
hiervon aber jetzt bin ich total
begeistert also wir haben die drohne
wiedergefunden ich hab das filmen können
mit meinem iphone und jetzt liegt sie
wieder hier alter das einfach nur kragen
an der stelle wo sich das sieht jetzt
allerdings auf den händen dass sie
lieber nicht gesponsert von diese
drohnen dings auch nicht von at gekommen
oder irgend so ein scheiß 1 500 den
controller verloren
machs gut ich suche drüben nee der ist
ja nicht bei mir ich glaube wir sind
düsseldorf dicker porsche mal vor ich
komme da
falls euch das video hier gefallen hat
meine damen und herren und ihr wollt
dass wir eventuell öfters und scheint
mit dieser kleinen drohne machen weil
man kann damit ihr auch noch challenges
machten die beispielsweise daran seien
nicht weg baum hoch weil sie waren
locker auf 100 200 meter höhe oder
irgendwie so auf samples kanal haben wir
auch ein video aufgenommen mit der
drohne das heißt das ziel ist auf jeden
fall in der beschreibung verlinkt und
jetzt meine damen und herren kommt das
auto auf das wasser ziehen
das war es jetzt hier vom wir können
jetzt hier mal den kanal abonnieren oder
hier unten meinen schenken ihr findet
ihr zwei andere videos und wenn ihr
schon seid könnt ihr auch die glocke
klicken dann willkommen die
benachrichtigungen
[Musik]